please welcome to the stage Carina
director of NetherRealm Studios and the
co-creator of Mortal Kombat
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Edie
you and your team at nether own Studios
have done it again there is so much to
unpack here and I'm sure you can't wait
to dive into some of the gameplay yeah
you know you
we've been biting our tongues since you
know six months ago around III dying to
dying to show you guys this game but we
really wanted to kind of build the
suspense this is absolutely gonna pay
off for that all right and I'll let you
do the honors take it away yeah you guys
first I think the first thing you wanted
to do is see the actual game so just
let's let's just roll them here
[Applause]
so we're very excited to show you first
look at Mortal Kombat 11 nobody else has
seen this today we have seven characters
to show you some returning some new
there's far more in this game to be able
to show you right here but we do want to
hit on the enhancements from the game of
fighting and the custom character
variations
[Applause]
Garrus is a new fighter in the game and
who can has a really cool time control
abilities you know immortal and
NetherRealm games we really try to add
something new Mortal Kombat X we
introduced a feature called a character
variations three versions of every
single character MK 11 is expanding on
that idea
creating custom character variations the
player can actually create die
themselves so you notice they're
selecting different versions of
scorpions somehow created by the player
some are created already in the game
same thing with maracas
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the gods and warriors are legendary why
don't you free eyes realm at the should
I buy you embrace nature works so this
is a Mortal Kombat games to expect the
fighting to be brutal MK 11 sees the
return of Baraka is a fan favorite from
Mortal Kombat 2 so let's see some of the
moves he does here that's to be outdone
scorpion has a few tricks up his sleeve
okay now without getting too technical
getting into some of the geeky fighting
game by what moments not their mortal
comp traditionally we've had one meter
that's a shared resource amongst the
offense defense and the super moves
mortal combat actually separating all
three of those so we have a horizontal
meter as the offense attacks vertical
meters the defensive attacks
SEPA rockets gonna shooting too using
his offensive moves also can extend this
leg staff here into a throw with a also
scorpion here is going to escape from a
knockdown using his defensive meter and
you're going to notice here that the
fatal blow is that's actually tied to
30% of the of the help meter one is
reduced you get fatal blow available
this adds completely new dynamic
intention to the fighting both in paraca
and scorpion have a fail for right now
Baraka wins this fight
so scorpion missus fatal blow attack but
it actually will regenerate after a
cool-down period so you notice is his
fatal flow is established he can pull it
off
[Music]
and now to be outdone Baraka now has his
fatal blow available
and of course it wouldn't be mortal
combat without fatalities
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]